rosi den weg wechseln und die frage was
politisch folgt und was momentan
diskutiert wird das ist ja dich heute
also ich hab mir da ich bin da zuständig
hierfür die absoluten knallharten thesen
die
große ärger großen ärger auslösen und
auch in die tiefe natürlich absolut
stimmen was mich einfach beruhigt und
ich glaube das ist ein problem das wir
den deutschen viel zu wenig wir
brauchten deutschland krank an seinen
berufspolitik ihr habt einfach viel zu
viele berufspolitiker hier die nicht für
den staat arbeiten sondern vom staat
leben sie sehen da das wunderbare senf
es für mich so typisch dieses kuschel
bild da haben sie im wahlkampf die
grünen und die fdp haben sich der ewige
feindschaft geschworen habe ich gesagt
die fdp ist unser natürlicher feind und
der länder hat großartige rhetorische
reden gehalten tausende davon um zu
sagen warum die grünen ganz schlimm sind
mann hat am anfang der koalitionsfrage
nicht am schluss hat man schon so ein
sell sie gemacht und warum was bedeutet
dass das bedeutet natürlich dass diese
gruppe von politikern die eigentlich
ganz anderer meinung sein müssen sind
hier vereint in diesem boot war jetzt
geht es darum macht zu erobern es winken
die posten die lukrativen renten das
prestige natürlich auch die kohle des
politikers entspannen sie plötzlich alle
zusammen nehmen platz dem raumschiff und
sind dann in ihrer abgehobenheit
berufspolitiker und vergessen da und das
interesse der bevölkerung und pflegen
ihr eigenes interesse deshalb ein
plädoyer hier in deutschland ganz
wichtig um diese berufspolitiker kosten
entgegenzuwirken
kannst du mir den job nicht wegnehmen
brauchen wir mehr direkte demokratie
nach schweizerischem vorbild damit diese
herrschaften die sich in diesen
koalitionsverhandlungen nur allzu
schnell lösen von ihren hehren
versprechen dass die gelegentlich daran
erinnert werden wer in der demokratie
eigentlich der chef ist nämlich nicht
diese hoch bezahlte berufspolitiker
sondern die bürgerin der bürger direkte
demokratie für deutschland wagen in
anwendung des unbestreitbaren satzes von
willy brandt béla anda ich erwarte jetzt
vorliegende zustellung oder wer auch
immer etwas dazu sagen mittag ist das
ist ein sprung bereit als schweizer
ehrenhalber muss ich das natürlich etwas
konterkarieren ja und nein ja wir haben
in deutschland an mehreren stellen ein
demokratiedefizit ja wir bräuchten mehr
direkte plebiszite der meinung bin ich
auch ja es ist ein fehler wenn
20-jährige sagen mein berufswunsch ist
politiker wenn wir also mit einer uns
freuen über eine große verjüngung des
parlaments kann das auch heißen dass der
anteil derer die von ihrem ganzen leben
nur von sich als politiker sehen
zugenommen hat das wären eher bedenklich
ich habe von einem politiker sein name
tut nichts zur sache gelesen er zieht
sehr oder über die liste noch ins
parlament komme weil er sei ja
berufspolitiker und wer nicht ins
parlament komme stehe er vor dem nichts
das würde ich sehr apart es gibt ja
abfindungsregelungen ruhegelder etc das
ist in der tat ein problem das wir zu
viele zu viele berufspolitiker haben die
meinen sie könnten danach nichts mehr
bisschen vielleicht allem wolfgang
schäuble der sich nur mit 970 glaube ich
für umsetzbar hält andererseits jedoch
glaube ich dass repräsentative wahlrecht
sollten wir nicht voreilig aufgeben es
hat auch seine moderierenden effekte das
also populisten rechter wie linker art
austariert werden in der mitte das also
nicht wenn jedes sau durchs dorf
getrieben wird dieser auch noch gleich
eine wahlurne auf dem rücken hat
sozusagen sondern dass wir diese
moderieren effekte einer repräsentativen
wahl haben allerdings bin ich dafür die
listenwahl zu überdenken ich finde wir
sollten also eine stärkere repräsentanz
vor ort haben also sollten das
mehrheitswahlrecht vor ort stärken das
andere nicht ganz abschaffen aber
stärken wir hatten jetzt mehrere fälle
bei sind politiker knall und fall ihren
wahlkreisen gescheitert das heißt sie
bekamen vor ort nicht dass man da der
leute die sie kennen müssen um sie im
bundestag zu vertreten und das sind sie
kalt oder freudig lächelnd über die
liste wird der besetzung allein das
parteiestablishment entscheidet doch in
den bundestag eingebracht würden
ganz schnell ganz schön was auch immer
wir hatten ja ganz aktuelle beispiele
bei denen in der bild zeitung ja auch
mit diesen durchstechereien oder diesen
cdu politikern die jetzt dem armin
laschet in den rücken fällt lauschen
aber weißt du denn dass das cdu
politiker war ja ich nehme es morgen
weil die nein die habe ich habe nicht
genau aber ich sage einfach los hat ja
auch so eine berufspolitische
abgehobenheit und den tag gelegt mit
diesem loch oder im flutgebiet wo er
quasi teil des raumschiffs geht an
meinem hintern vorbei wenn da ein paar
häuser weggeschwemmt werden das hatten
sich die leute verrückt und jetzt diese
politiker dem in den rücken fallen und
da an die medien durch stechen um lage
zu destabilisieren
das sind eben auch noch tun einmal ein
rein ordnen rangiert damit alle ohren
kommt anders dastehen nein was das die
unsere zuschauer verstehen was passiert
also es gab gestern eine
sondierungsrunde oder vorgestern mit der
fdp und der union dann am ende ja
einzelne inhalte bei bild zu lesen waren
heute gab es wieder eine runde aus union
und grünen und auch da wieder gab es
inhalte die bei bild de zu lesen waren
unter anderem ging es darum dass die
grünen sich insbesondere auch nicht
wirklich überraschend beim thema
migration beim thema steuern beim thema
nämlich steuern beim thema eu
finanzierung
sich nicht einig waren und das offenbar
einer grünen partei viele davon ausgehen
dass ist richtung ampel geht aber was
passiert denn ihr hier sehen wir doch
paul darf das nicht sagen aber es ist
auch ganz klar hier kommt aus
unionskreisen jeden tag oder aus
interessierten kreisen ein hinweis wo es
zeigt das funktioniert nicht mit jamaika
arminias ist bleiben das ist ja die
botschaft die uns hier gesendet wird
sicherlich nicht von armin laschet
persönlich aber aus dem erweiterten
umfeld inklusive der csu ich will dir
keinen verdächtigen aber das würde ich
mir tatsächlich dort auch mitnehmen als
botschaft und ich würde mich wirklich
fragen wie lang tue ich mir das noch an
und lass mich so dieser wohin jeden tag
aufs neue dass eine spannende frage
bilder weil wenn wir das thema direkte
demokratie diskutieren und die frage
sozusagen dann am ende auch wie
kandidaten zustande kommen kann man ja
auch die frage stellen ob dann
vielleicht das us system am ende wo es
vor wahlen gebe vorwahlen bei dann der
cdu dies gegeben hätte und dann hätte es
wahrscheinlich
den anderen kandidaten gegeben
schink wahl entweder hätte es dann
friedrich merz getroffen oder am ende
dann markus söder wir das besser gleich
auch noch beitragen
der war ja auch noch aber bei der
basisversorgung blieb natürlich scheint
ja total ich hätte das wesentlich besser
gefunden was ich aber auch mal nach und
doch zu laschet sagen möchte es hat ja
nicht nur an dem an dem kandidaten
gekränkt ist hat er innerhalb der union
was von box den laschet how den laschet
und zwar nicht erst jetzt sondern auch
schon während des ganzen wahlkampf ist
und da ist wirklich es hat aber nun auch
viele fehler gemacht muss man so ja das
haben wenn man wirklich jetzt mal ganz
ehrlich wenn man sich scholz anschaut
und zb den warburg skandal ja ich werde
jetzt können wir wieder vorher heute
sind auf stöckchen aber letztlich nichts
mit hölzchen auf stöckchen soll ich sage
nur die spd wenn da so ein soll
dagewesen wäre hätten ihnen warburg
skandal jeden tag immer wieder aufs
parkett gebracht hätte saskia esken sagt
jack lage olaf scholz kanzler werden ja
klar dann hätten alle gedacht auch die
die eher links gestimmten der wähler den
will ich auf gar keinen fall den will ja
die eigene partei nicht genau das ist
bei laschet passiert deswegen ja ich bin
total für das system vor wann hast du
gesagt hast mein anderer vorschlag ist
aber was mich noch viel mehr stört ist
wie die ministerposten verschachert
werden nehmen wir mal annalena baerbock
den ihr direktmandat übrigens mal wieder
nicht errungen sind könnte jetzt
außenministerin werden da frage ich mich
wirklich ich weiß sie erklärt ja immer
gerne in ihrem völkerrecht und sie ist
ja ganz bewandert mit ihrem master an
der energie die wir uns auch eine sehr
gute uni ist aber was ich sagen will ist
die minister london school of economics
ist natürlich grandios spieler an leute
aus studiert aber was ich sagen will ist
die ministerposten da wäre es mir viel
wichtiger dass es wie ein fähigkeit
bogen gibt
ein kompetentes man ja was ich muss sich
etwas ergeben sich meine diese
diskussion zeigt euch das wunderbar
jetzt diskutieren wir hier auch über
diese posten und dieses geschachere und
die das ist auch das spannendste
ins grundsätzliche in einer demokratie
geht es doch nicht um diese
ministerposten es geht doch darum dass
ihr parteien kommen mit einem auch
auftrag mit einem intellektuellen
auftrag den sie sich selber gegeben hat
und die der welt in der welt
die website sogar ganz gut sichtbar an
politiker sitzen zusammen der eine sagt
lass uns über politik reden was wird aus
mir
hat es ja mal selbst gesagt dass wir
jetzt so was wir sagen ja das heißt die
leute entweder das heute des hilfs
gespräch da nicht stehen aber ich will
diese doch noch in diesem sich in diesem
sinne machen der wähler geht vergessen
in diesen ganzen verein und auch diese
cdu-politiker die du erwähnt hast das
sind ja eben auch macht dekadente leute
wichtigtuer die sich jetzt bei den
medien aufspielenden laschet vorher
unterstützt haben weil sie glaubt im
schlafwagen bringt er sie zu seinen
lukrativen ministerposten kam ist er in
schwierigkeiten demontieren zerfleischen
sie sich selbst und da sieht man einfach
das sind politiker die vergessen haben
um was es eigentlich geht und darum
direkte demokratie
ganzen politiker ist eben kaputt nein
ich finde das geht auch nicht was das
ist auch demokratie verdruss den wir
hier prägen durch solche äußerungen ich
respektiere die koppel unglaublich schön
sein für seine scharfzüngigkeit aber ich
bin der rosi da hier gehst du so weit es
geht in der politik natürlich auch um
das durchsetzen von interessen es geht
um das durchsetzen von machtansprüchen
dazu braucht man posten auch von
politischen vorstellungen wer das nicht
will der ist in der politik falsch am
platz der ringe reichen ob ich bin ein
gegenbeispiel er den wollen die du noch
begleitet das damals schröder und
vermerken dann haben die welt die
parteien gewisse ansagen gemacht zu den
steuern die beide tiefer worden während
des wahlkampfs als das worauf sie sich
dann geeinigt haben in den
koalitionsverhandlungen das ist der
punkt den ich meine ich bin nicht gegen
die posten ich bin nicht gegen einen
minister bin ich gegen die institution
aber ich sage dass das system der
repräsentativen demokratie dazu neigen
kann dass die politiker als
interessengruppe abhebt demokrat aber
ich bin 100 prozentige demokrat oder
heben wir unser wasser
[Musik]